hi everyone and welcome to the second
day of the conference my name is krishy
Sharma I'm a software engineer at an AI
consulting firm in the US Austin Texas
and for the last 60 days I've been
traveling Europe and learning a ton
about the food and culture but something
that's really fascinated me is the
differences between the US and the EU in
regards to technology and particularly
data
privacy I learned that when I was in
Munich at uh the deuts museum I don't
know if I said it right but um
apparently there is a German law that
prohibits you from taking pictures of
people if their faces are um
noticeable in public and that's just
something new for me from the US um so
that's my first taste of some of the
stringent laws here in the EU um and
then on my second St I was in Lithuania
and I started realizing that no matter
where I was um there was always a form
on the internet that I had to click for
cookies so there's cookie compliance due
to the gdpr regulation I
believe and then yesterday I was in
Brussels walking around and I happened
upon the EU Parliament which I Learned
was in Brussels just yesterday and I saw
some Notions around the AI act um that
is being discussed currently and of this
made me realize when I saw on the
screens in Brussels you know all of the
different things and proposals um that
really all of these regulations even
though it makes Innovation kind of hard
is to try to make a better future for
technology um and so this is very
different for me and this really helped
me understand that even though um you
know red tape can be difficult there are
ways to kind of continue poast it so as
somebody from an AI consulting firm my
biggest question would be you know how
do we continue to innovate despite some
of these laws that are saying you know
hey like now we as users get to control
what data these companies can take from
us so how do we build AI from sensitive
data so we're going to go on that
Journey today and we're going to build
you know well not via code but just talk
about how to build a voice assistant
that we're going to name Ti from using
our like voice message data on our
phones so we're going to start with the
class classical ml approach and we just
want to see if there's any way that we
can kind of protect data privacy knowing
that there are more and more regulations
coming up and knowing that this is kind
of the climate that we're in in terms of
you know what people want as
well so with classical machine learning
you have a central server that contains
you know the compute that you're going
to need to train your model and then we
have maybe like your cell phone and your
tablet and your laptop all with the data
that we'd need to train our voice
assistant so the data would have to be
sent from our devices to the central
server where the compute is and then
some you know company like the company
that's creating TI right so that's also
us right now but we would basically
collect all that data and then train one
model so this is is fine except for it
has a few
limitations um the first is you know the
data privacy so in countries where maybe
you have to ask for consent you may not
be able to get any access to that data
which could reduce the diversity that
you have in your training
data the second one is security so you
know if you're storing all of this data
on a central server then if there's an
attack or a data breach um it can be
very harmful to your users but also you
know to you as your company
and your reputation as different
companies have seen in the past and
three it's not very scalable I mean it's
going to take a long time to train this
model as we get more and more data and
more and more
users
so then we can look to maybe distributed
machine learning to try to see if
there's some ways to make this
better so with distributed machine
learning you have still all of your
devices with the data and that data is
being collected at the central server
again so it doesn't really do anything
for Point number one which is the data
privacy
component but we'll see if it does
anything better so with all the data
collected Central
server um basically our methodology is
going to subset the data and then
distribute it across to different nodes
and each of those nodes will train a
local model so so this should speed up
training but it actually increases the
security risk because you have to now go
and protect the data across all of the
nodes depending on your infrastructure
and
architecture but this will give you a
global model so it is more scalable
because you can leverage as many nodes
as you want as you grow your
users but in these instances we're
seeing that the data is traveling to
where the compute is meaning that the
data has to leave our personal
devices so how can we get the compute to
just travel to where the data is already
stored so that's where Federated
learning comes into play um this was a
question that Google researchers had
back in 2018 when they first developed
Federated learning because they wanted
to come up with a way that they could
continue training and creating AI
particularly in heavily regulated
Industries like healthcare and
Telecommunications in Federated learning
you have a similar setup so you have the
central server and then all of your
devices that have the
data but rather than the data
transferring to the central server so
being sent off and you know taken to
nowhere land where you have no idea
where it is the data lives on your
device and each of your devices will now
train a local model using your personal
data and rather than sending your
information or your data to the central
server the model weights are transferred
from the device to the server so each
device is going to send you know the
weights from the model that it trained
as well as the parameters and metrics
but it should have no like identifiable
information so all of that is collected
in the server and the server then
Aggregates it using whatever averaging
method that you and your team decide on
so we're just going to use a basic one
in our voice assistant Ty and that will
create a global model so that model will
allow us to scale across as many users
because it's still actually leveraging
the same Concepts as distributed machine
learning as it's Distributing but rather
than Distributing across nodes on a
central server that some company owns
it's Distributing across you know our
own
devices and it also helps us with the
data privacy issue as the data never has
to leave the consumer's device so you
know the it could help with some of the
regulations that might stipulate against
that and third it reduces the need for
concern around security around the data
because now our server only has model
weights and parameters and it doesn't
have sensitive information that could
lead to a lot of issues if we don't have
the correct networking or if we have a
misconfigured
firewall so so my team and I at Kung Fu
AI used Federated learning recently when
we were creating a model for a client
that we have that could predict breast
cancer 5 years before onset and the only
way we could do it was using Federated
learning due to the Hippa regulations in
the US that prevent you from moving data
off of the original server where it's
stored so when we landed upon this
approach we wanted to know like what
tools would make it easiest to get
started since it seemed pretty daunting
to have to set up these kind of
networking and Communications to send
the model weights back and forth on our
own and luckily there's already a lot of
work out there so we looked at three
main Frameworks the first one is pift
which is probably the most popular and
well-known um pift is was built
originally by piie torch lightning and
it can support a few different um um
Frameworks and has a lot of more
advanced settings that maybe somebody
who is very detailed in Federated
learning would be able to
leverage but it isn't as research
friendly and we were in the research and
development phase of our
product so we tried to understand the
documentation but PFT was also going
through more um changes so we didn't
really use it because it wasn't really
user friendly at the moment when we
developing so the second tool that we
looked into was tensorflow Federated so
tensorflow Federated was developed by
tensorflow Google and it works very well
with the tensorflow framework and it
doesn't work with other
Frameworks it also requires in-depth
knowledge about tensorflow and at our
consulting firm we tend to use a lot of
different Frameworks depending on the
use case we also hadn't locked down
which framework to use so we would
prefer to use a tool that was framework
agnostic so this one also was abandoned
after a few
tries um and it was a little while later
after some more Googling that we found a
smaller package called flower and flower
it was developed by a research company
actually pretty close by in Hamburg
Germany and it was framework agnostic as
well as having more of like a research
friendly the documentation and tools so
you could easily set up the
configuration for the
server and the different devices which
are called clients in flower um without
having to know too much about Federated
learning or having used it without
having had to use it in the
past so our team decided to go with
flower and it really helped us get
started on something that we had never
used before
so with flower you
can um just get started with a few lines
of code and we're going to go through
that at the end with a little demo the
way flower works is that you have your
devices which are called flower clients
and you have your flower server which is
a central server and you uh basically
need to send the model weights from the
one local model from your first device
device or any device that you configure
it to to the server so that the server
can initialize like a starting Global
model that starting Global model was
will then send those weights down to all
of the
clients and we'll kick off training
across all of the
devices so training will
happen and then an evaluation step will
run and then you'll get your model
weights sent back back so these are like
updated model weights now from each of
the different devices those updated
model weights are sent to the server
which
then Aggregates it using some averaging
formula that you've defined and
basically you kick off a few more rounds
so you can Define how many rounds you
need the more rounds tends to lead to
better results until like a while when
you have marginal return but it allows
for you to get a more a better picture
of all of the clients training data and
models so flower allows for you to
Define your own metric aggregation
formula which is like you know how
you're going to calculate your loss or
how you're going to average all of your
M you know different metrics that you're
tracking for your model your Global
model it also allows you to aggregate
your model um so those are like the
actual model weights so you can use like
weighted average feder Federated average
which is just a simple average or
something that you've defined and then
it also allows you to compress those
model weights so you can have a faster
transfer between each of your devices
and the server itself since there's a
lot more communication going on you're
going to want it to be faster so it does
that as
well um okay so now it's time for the
demo and
and I'm going to try to share my screen
so let me know if it isn't big enough if
the code isn't big enough that
happened I might
Al do you mind helping me sorry I don't
know if I know exactly how you dragged
it
over yeah
on the projector
uh then I have an
[Music]
idea do okay
okay
so can you all read
this okay thank
you so to get started with flower um you
just import it like a normal python
library and you just Define the that
you're going to start your server and
all you need to do is have your server
address and and a config so the only
thing you really need to Define in the
config is a number of rounds although I
do do believe there might be a default
set it might be something like a 100 so
you might want to set it yourself anyway
if you're just
experimenting um so for this we're going
to do four rounds and four rounds is
basically four rounds of training across
all of your
devices and then you can also Define a
strategy so we're just using Federated
average so that strategy is what the
central server will use to accumulate
all of the model weights once it's
received all of the data like or the
model weights from the clients it's
going to use this Federated averaging
formula which is a simple average
formula that's provided by
flower um and that's how it will
determine what the new set of Weights is
to send back to the
clients so that is how you set up the
server and then for the client
so we in our demo are going to
use okay this is where the bulk of the
code is um we're going to use three
clients and we're just going to call
them one two three that's the device ID
but you basically so device ID is saying
like hey what are the different names of
all of these devices that I'm looking
out for the server is going to be
listening in on port 8080 for us that's
what we've said it for any devices that
are trying to connect so we're going to
have to give our devices the server
address so that they know what to reach
out to and we're also going to have to
provide each of our devices or flower
clients a model for local training so
the model is we're just going to use a
simple mnus model and I'm not going to
really review this one too much because
it's more around how to create an ml
model and not not necessarily Federated
learning but you can see here that you
have you know the model creation and all
of the data
splitting and the model fit which is the
important part
so those are the key components before
we run it I'll will also show you I just
set up like the server config so you can
set up how many clients that you want it
to fit on and if you have end up having
like a hundred devices thousand devices
you can say like hey I only want a
fraction of this and that allows for you
to have faster training so you don't
have to wait for every single device to
connect in case some are having
networking
issues
so with this we're going to start our
server and I think this might be too
small but let me is that so if you can't
read it um basically it's saying you
know that flower is starting it's
initializing global parameters but for
it to set the initial parameters it
needs at least one random client so this
means our server is up but we need to
get at least one client up so we're
going to
use this shell script that I created
which basically just uses Docker to kick
off a client using the client.py script
that I showed you earlier or that's up
here and we're going to give the device
ID of one since this is set to to listen
to whatever I put in the
terminal
so this is just downloading the data
that's how I set it up so it can
download it and split it each time but
um basically once this runs and chains
the model it's going to send those
parameters back to our server which will
acknowledge the fact that it now has
parameters and is ready for the other
devices to connect to it
so it's saying that um it's connected
and that the server is now ready so the
server says that it's received the
parameters it's evaluated it and
Federated learning is
starting
um but really when it says starting um
normally my team knows that it still
needs to connect to other devices so I
think it's kind of like not exactly
accurate but it's ready to start is kind
of what it means um
so we're going to run our next two
clients and both of these should kind of
give similar messages um in terms of
connecting to the server and being able
to send their weights back and forth
over a few rounds
so it'll probably take a few
seconds but at the end we should see
that once
the um clients have connected to the
server and the training has finished the
four rounds the server will
automatically close the
connection
okay so this time it is able to move
past that connectivity step and you can
see that each round it's calculating the
different metrics I can try to make it a
bit bigger but I don't really know how
to make the terminal bigger besides
this is it
okay command
plus
[Music]
um no thank you well um this all this
code is up on GitHub so you can also run
it um locally and see the exact logs but
it's basically telling you the metrics
for each Epoch for each training round
so if there's five epochs that's how I
said it and all of the four training
rounds and then on our server we see
that it's been able to calculate the
metrics you know it's telling us that
the loss is minimizing over each of the
four rounds and that it's finished and
the exit the server has exited
so uh now I need to go back to the
presentation
okay so to further improve our model
that we're creating we could add more
Cent clients and different data sets
which would increase the diversity um of
our training data we could also optimize
the hyperparameters for the models on
each of the clients so the the models
that are training locally that's
typically called client side um you
could kind of twist or configure the
different um knobs on that to make the
model itself better and then you can
also test out the different model
aggregation techniques on the server to
figure out if there's a better way to
average the model weights and then send
them back
down so overall Federated learning
provides a secure way to train the model
um and it allows you to have faster
predictions because the predictions are
going to happen straight on the device
and it doesn't need to go and contact
some Central server it also lends to
Diversified training data set because
now you can actually access um you know
greater sets of data that you you might
not have access to either under
regulation or consent or because it
didn't fit the exact um like parameters
that you would need out of a data set
for your training data set through
classical machine
learning there are a few drawbacks and
this is something that I think more
research and more youth would help with
but um you're constrainted to the
compute resources on each of the clients
so if there's not enough compute on your
device and you can't really train the
model on there you also need fast and
reliable networking so like if you have
no internet then you can't communicate
to the server to send the model weights
which is a problem um and then you also
don't have any access to that data so
you can't label it and you can't clean
it um in the way that you're we're
traditionally used to with machine
learning but all is that to say is that
there's still the ability to do digital
transformation with these regulations
and we can still continue to improve on
technology even though it may feel like
sometimes red tape makes it
harder um so that's the end of my talk
and the first link is to uh GitHub where
this repo that I used for the demo is
online along with the shell scripts and
everything that I used um so if you're
interested in trying it out I would
definitely copy that down the second one
is just a link to my personal website
and contact and the third one is an a
link or the actual website URL for my
company Kung
fu. so yeah I'm open to
questions